citizens of the rejection we are back with another
DC Animated Universe film not a DC AMU mind you
because we are watching part one of two of The
Dark Knight Returns now this is back to 2012.
we're not done with the present we're not done
with the future we're gonna watch all of these
but in the comments I'd like you to let me know
which one you want us to watch next after part
two we're watching part two next that's inevitable
then we're diving back in so let us know in the
comments also remember to like this video so we
know that you in fact liked this video hit that
notification Bell so you know when more of these
comes and remember to share that Constantine video
because it's the first one that has done less than
the rest and frankly we liked it it's intense it's
a hard R you want R-rated animated films you need
to to know they're popular and who knows maybe DC
is watching the reactions they're like well you
see this why we stopped making our rude movies
it's not you it's on you somehow it's your
responsibility so share that one particularly
because I want to make more the more
of the constant demons because we like
those so let us know in the comments hit that
notification bell all the YouTube things and
if you want to watch this in its entirety from
the beginning to the end without edits in its
full potent glory and are watching faces
then head on over to the patreon because
the patrons get the full experience if you'd
like to watch us watch you watch us that's the
place to do it alright without any further Ado
whatsoever it is The Dark Knight Returns part one
[Music]
I think cars are coming sounds like
racing cars it's not open with cars
I'm going Airfield oh planes okay okay
nope ah you were right it's Gotta Have cars
the blimps always the blimps [Music]
yes live life a quarter mile at a time everyone
knows he's redlining hit the nuts [Music]
ah
[Applause] [Music] [Applause]
foreign
so what happens when you try to
push past mach 10 Maverick come on
coffin for billionaire Bruce Wayne for sure turns
out Wayne bailed out at the last second suffering
only minor burns I like his Bat racing helmet
yeah just a little yep no I don't figure out
this is Batman death threats have once again been
leveled by the mutants again soon to retire 70
year old Commissioner James Gordon damn I've
got one more month at this job and I'd love
to spend it nailing the mutants if they want to
take me on come and get me I got one month left
of this [__] almost too old tonight also marks
the 10th anniversary of the last sighting of the
of that wherever he is he's enjoying a toast
with good friends great job at adapting the
animation style it looks like Frank Miller her
hair and like the the bulkiness and the mutant
they're not like the usual Street Crooks
there's no Humanity in them at all sounds
like someone I used to deal with things are
different now Bruce the government the public
they wouldn't stand for you anymore I don't
know about that Jim talk to Dick lately you
know I haven't shame you didn't keep up
with him after what happened with Jason oh
foreign that's how I dance
that's why I don't dance
he's just dancing in the wrong City
that's true I gotta find a Gotham in 2049.
damn it Wolverine
no no every time there's a sale on jewelry brings
him back don't go up Billy go around behind him
slice and dice show him we're nasty come on oh
no can't do it when they into it can't do it
when they're done revisiting a traumatic memory
he was just thinking about pearls I can tell
oh floor oh
man I should have gone to therapy
a little EMDR might have helped oh
foreign
balls just remembering a promise Alfred
never again sorry I woke you when did you
shave oh wait it fell off when did I shave
I think he cares about the weather I don't
think this one's cared about anything for a
long time guy doesn't even sweat look at him
he makes me sick great doctors man just such
good bedside manner don't be nervous Harvey
Dr willing and I have done outstanding
work on you I'm confident you're ready
to face the world and say hey I'm okay
and you look great too sure let's see it
oh I don't expect the people of Gotham City
to forgive my crimes overnight I only
ask that they give me a second chance
see oh kidnapping and murdering young children
a line even the limits hadn't crossed until now
despite the family paying the ransom the mutants
still took the boy's life Wow many are already
calling the worst criminals Gotham City has
seen since the Joker that's a direct challenge
presentation of Tyrone Power in the mark of
Zorro maybe just don't watch TV I don't know
it feels like it's not for you yeah it's like
the same three news channels in this and Trump
why do I have the Zorro and News Network it's a
weird cable package Bruce it's the bat package
got PTSD man
about to hit Gotham oh
you try to hold me back but you're
weak you're nothing but a hollow shell
that is an image [Music]
man this is such a harrowing animated
film I never really captured Frank
Miller's dread and they're letting
it breathe which I appreciate yeah I
like that it's part one and part two
so you can honor it sometimes come
cool dang
oh come in here where it's warm mommy yeah
please no dark soft and make me feel safe
well yeah kill that guy Hawks off to make
me feel safe get pain in me Joanie you're
messing with my livelihood whoa
hey man take it somewhere else
I just had the seats cleaned shut
your hairy face and Drive Alabaster
a new master
Mess With Me Nobody messes with the bear you dig
left the mink damn I gotta get away with the cash
your blood money yeah you don't profit off of
being an [__] I heard the mutants hang here oh
is that Sophia lillis would play a good Stephanie
Brown oh sure at least the lights are bright just
gotta find a way to make her hair do that I
mean the 80s is stranger things tastic as is
[Music]
that's a gun my dude
where'd you go oh yeah oh nice yeah
love when they do the strobing
effect with his movements and
stuff always Batman always up there freaking weird
yeah nice that was sick oh cool I didn't think
of that when I saw the lightning that was perfect
iconic frame for a show kid I slowed
down there you are that's so cool
[Applause]
that was the Batman oh the Condominiums soon
to be built and soon to be destroyed these men
are mine you heard the man you crazy I'm going in
rookie come on rookie like the seasoned cop just
enjoying the time he's been waiting for this this
floor don't feel safe live dangerously and shut up
that's not what people mean when they say
live dangerously my God that's living dumb
nice yeah he's a big old guy that's
a hell of a climb he's a thick Batman
floor safer now freaky you never made noise before
oh steps
Batman's just out there with fake horse hopes
oh now you've done it
you're under arrest Mister you just
crippled that man he's young he'll
walk again but you'll stay scared
won't you punk I mean it get away
from him he's being patient with you as
it is kid nice to have your backpacks
yes I was a rookie like schmuck face there
and tell Gordon we have to talk but how's he
supposed to get in touch with you you know
how this goes now both sides are two-faced
but they both look like Harvey Dent um we will
kill the old man Gordon I myself will kill the
fool back fool don't call us a gang we are
the law Gotham City belongs to the mutants
you seemed like a gang at criminals pretty
textbook Cyclops let himself go really dark place
entire matter immediately my client is the
victim here Merkel draw Up release papers
for a victim here whoa whoa whoa wait a second
you're releasing him right now interesting fun
I'm still the prime beneficiary
in your will aren't I
Alfred always Alfred such an inheritance
coming your way for the last year of your life
Alfred lives forever he's like
Keith Richards that is true all
that stress is pickled them like
the drugs are getting pictures
another Batman so now you're going to tell me
what he's up to stay away from me I got rights
ugh you're also bleeding to death and
right now I'm the only one in the world
who can get you to a hospital in time so
how quickly you decide to talk is up to
you sounds like Peter Weller it does
I wonder if it is outfit isn't there
any other way to contact him at least a
dozen then why so everyone knows hidden
two helicopters stolen last night got to
be two-faced he's scratching both sides
now I wouldn't rule out that he's hurting
himself we're still talking about dent a
Target that needs two helicopters
that's twice as big as anyone can
oh the Gotham life building I'm absolutely
convinced [Music] games t-shirts neurotics
like Harvey drawing them into corresponding
intersecting patterns you could say Batman oh no
committing the crimes using his so-called villains
as narcissistic proxies of course he wakes
foreign
[Music]
great too yeah this is Harvey Dent right
now I'm sitting Atop The Beautiful Gotham
life building right now I'm posing as hush two
bombs big enough to make both Towers Rubble you
have 22 minutes to save them and my price is 22
million dollars and two tacos for Taco Tuesday
and two bags split evenly a two
two smoke bumps good Batman's on
brand theme he creates his village
you know it makes on him to play by their rules
cool
they're so good at making the poses
work oh the Frank Miller poses yeah
beautiful adaptation of the art
whoa sick there's some fear toxic [__]
you're drugs kids not those drugs what's happening
your favorite nightmare should last about an hour
two minutes of course I mean naturally
how do I stop it stop it it shouldn't be going oh
he said we'd get the money and run the bombs are
just for show he wants to die and take thousands
with him can you stop it across your fingers
oh I don't know if you freeze
a bomb froze time itself
whoa damn foreign
[Music]
s
or Rises you know what I mean
no show me what did you do he's got four faces
now I played a long as long as I could just
look at me and have your laugh at least both
sides match now right they couldn't fix me oh
nice commissioner ah wait forgot bean
sprouts well it sounds like she's got
you eaten right gotta watch the red
meat you know everyone's a doctor
look at prices nice collection
good good at this boat [__]
a lot of Alan more love can we just zoom in on
the comic rack please just live there for a second
oh
oh poor guy I love that I
don't remember I know say
a mission to G Gordon has been shot
and killed oh sorry I read that wrong
oh man I'm 17 years old Macho cop
remember Chicago her parents are great that was
great use of silhouette yeah cowabunga Robin
good you got the the upper body strength
gymnastics training Galaxy broadcasting
President James Olson assured viewers
that the television writers strike now
in its fourth year what will not affect
this season's program oh God now it is
fourth year oh no and was that Jimmy
Olsen reporting two topical too topical
oh man itself hold your breath once we get the
ransom we flush the whole kid jeez crank is pissed
man
feel like it's a very Frank
Miller character it's great
ah Chill Spot it's just a bat
and it doesn't mean anything
whoa dude what is the turnover rate with
the mutants hi very high out of the way
spot yeah that was so cool back off or I'll
kill him believe me man I'll do it [Applause]
and look at that the kid's calm is a cucumber
now combat weapons you're going to tell me
why you got them I'll tell you but no
cops you're in no position to negotiate
wow [Laughter] nice surgical reveal
I slideways look out I'm trying to make an honest
living here stay out of my business
what you know what those words mean
goodbye Keanu Reeves
you've been selling weapons to the mutants my
wife she's dying oh they wouldn't pay for the
treatment you sent them enough Firepower to Stage
a small War if it's War they want I've got just
the thing I'm not talking speeches man talking
War the dump in one hour so get in the dump
whoa who else of course but the signal is coming
from in a while since I've taken her out still
purrs like it was yesterday hers like Earth a kid
bat tank Gotham City belongs belong to the mutants
are you sure about that
mutants
so trigger happy I don't even wait
for an order kids today no respect
Batman doesn't have his one rule in the
future nope he's he's too old for this [__]
nice I want to make a Batman the
Stars Rodney Dangerfield and call
it the Batman who could get no respect cosigned
man
you really did give them enough for a small
army for a war nothing against the bat tank
like how did the Army not notice all of this
[Music] Awesome's a bad place no oversight
rubber grenades you know uh
it's the thought that counts
all this metal and you don't even do this look
at that it's just a shell to keep you safe
and face me like a man
sir you can't seriously
he's in his time he'll kill you
it's the only way I'll know wow
[Music]
hello
[Music] oh
you slow Spud
don't bring us back oh get in there kiddo
oh broke his visor
he already had to fix his Bat
logo once today come on you
[Applause] that name
oh man
you don't need that now oh plus that's for Robin
oh
yes [Applause] oh yeah
whoa cool
Clayface
I need a nap of Justice it's just a snap
[Music]
come on it's very strong that is a 300 pound
man yeah that's gonna be the
heaviest body uphill in mud
girl thank you now run along home [Laughter]
nope now hold your breath yeah foreign
clever girl
the batsling it's your name
Carrie Carrie Kelly yeah sorry audience Stephanie
Brown and very different Rob apologies apologies
failed the city one job koi failed this city
for 45 minutes people have been yelling at me
it's cursing your credibility it's been like a
15-year window since I've read this Stephanie
brownson likes the current run of the I'm sorry
no you need to defend this yeah I do immediately
before these comments get I have
she's not even a robin oh the gallery
I think that she's standing just
adjacent to the other yeah good call
[Music] hands to yourself please the
password's just I mean that's fair
Alfred that that should be hacking where'd
he go to find his strength he's gonna watch
Zorro again this is a marathon on TV
what he does so the news watches Zorro
show us the butt man bat booty I feel like Frank
Miller would have shown us
the butt man that's true
I'm not finished yet and
you are not finished with me
oh
dang all the scars
me
oh he is a monster striking at the foundations
of our democracy where are the principles that
make this the noblest country in the world
frankly I'm surprised around a thousand more
like them damn those glasses thank you Scott
Summers tonight we'll examine his impact on
our society from Metropolis managing editor of
the daily oh it was a lot of Lang Gotham City
popular psychologist and author of the
best seller hey I'm okay Dr Bartholomew
walper oh the Frank Miller satire is great
the misleading short-term statistics but
in the long term a whole generation of young
people will be bent to The Matrix of Batman's
pathological self-delusion hey The Matrix
a man has risen to remind us that the power
[Music]
this one man is showing us that we
can take a stand power to the people
with lots of money and
resources yeah the one percent
among those captured is one they're calling the
mutant leader I broke his bones now my Mutant Army
is coming to storm Gotham City Batman got my nose
poop kill Gordon we will raise Gotham and taste
its blood prepare for war prepare for trouble
and make it double Captain yindle stands firmly
against the Batman I intend to personally sit down
with the mutant leader to negotiate a settlement
what do you think Trish oh this is a praise too
between this his strong stand on Batman and his
choosing a woman as the next Police Commissioner
I think we're seeing a whole new mayor public
perception wise that is of course yeah good good
reminder do enjoy the talking head interstitials
I love it it makes it feel so much more like
a movie yeah and it gives you so much scope
how are you doing Mr Mayor evening commissioner
of course it didn't take long
wow
wow bear is dead
mayor Stevenson had this to say if there are any
members of the mutant game organization listening
is gels she's perfect with her help I can end
the mutant problem once and for all have you
forgotten what happened with Jason dang it'll
take weeks to prepare you properly but I have
a job for you tonight alter my plan in any
way straight from my instructions at all
and you're fired and I will not give
you a reference for your next gig
Batman so Frank Miller the pipe West River and 4
mandatory didn't hear it from me Spud
I like that mix of like British slang
where they use rhyme scheme but also
like 80 slang yes with their mutant hood that
was I love the language you're a good cop truth
truth mine since I was a kid I don't understand
Batman [Music] let's not talk about Batman
of course we heard about the
pipe of course you did whatever
oh I'm sure you've heard old fossils like me
talk about Pearl Harbor truth is we were scared
stiff we were hiding in our beds with our heads
under the sheets oh and then we heard President
Roosevelt on the radio taking our fear and turning
it into a fighting spirit is why we won that war
Batman's President Roosevelt yeah I still
don't see what that has to do with Batman
maybe one day you will take the cycle
back to the cave you're done for tonight
how do you know it worked and then voice Alfred
for your hours [Laughter] thousands of them the
only way to finish this is to defeat them
humiliate them I'm counting on you One Last
Time You Gotta pants all of them and film it come
down to say hello old man I Came to Say Goodbye
ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha
[Laughter] foreign
the pipe
[Music]
know yourself I will show you who
ruled Gotham City okay son show me son
dude damn you're slow true but we're
all slow and we're thriving mud
ha ha sure had mutants voice familiar too
come on bats foreign what was that just the right
kind of Cut Above the eyes the kind it bleeds
leader Billy berserk Rob he Peg Batman you see are
we getting Pagan scene oh Deadpool get it get it
oh boy oh no
[Applause]
oh is that a tickle that was a nerve
bundle in your deltoid might not
have hurt but you won't be moving
that arm for a while nerve bundle
oh
you finished old man hey this isn't a mud hole
it's an operating table damn
oh
now turn them over and spank him in
front of everybody God damn [Music]
the mutants what we are the sons of Batman
and Gotham's criminals are about to enter
politics it works oh it's so good just
a bunch of Vigilantes sons of Batman
oh get your half eaten donut he's earned
it I know I should have been afraid but
this is my block the guy was mugging a lady in
front of my shop so I murdered him with this
the Batman has infected the minds of Gotham's
youth poisoned these so-called sons of Batman
with an Insidious excuse for the most so
a bunch of psychopaths turn on criminals
instead of the rest of us and you want to
blame Batman I say more power to them sweet
[Music]
oh cool dude that was legit so Jay Lev has
been directing like most of them but that
was I think like one of the better directed
animated movies I've seen well yeah I mean
this seemed like and and certainly I imagine
uh dividing Peter Weller great choice I feel
like we've heard it maybe one other time
as Batman maybe am and then Ariel Winter
I know that name was she Robin maybe
maybe David Selby was that big bad guy
or we're getting into the Weeds now yeah I don't
know these names but yeah like dividing it up into
two parts I imagine really gives you like Frank
Miller books at least in my experience certainly
seem to have that air and that you know I mean
along with all those really strong lights and
shadows I just feel like comes with a lot of
atmosphere I love that uses like a storyboard
yeah like a lot of times adaptations don't and I
feel like this directing was great because they
like loved the source material well yeah it's like
it has I think I think you're right it's like it
has a nice blend of the Miller stylings with some
of that Batman animated series quality worked in
damn that's why Bradley Baker Michael Emerson's
Joker that's cool Michael Jackson was Alfred
Terror strong
all right Bruce Tim was uh Thomas Wayne oh
that's great oh I didn't catch who the big
bad was yeah we gotta go back but I'm excited to
hear uh Michael Emerson as the Joker yeah it's
gonna be a lot of fun I like that legitimate I
love that Bruce Tim produced this and also voice
Thomas Wayne but like Bruce Tim's such a legend
in the bat space got that new show coming yeah on
Amazon now no longer an HBO but on Amazon but yeah
like the way they might see a lot of that oh sure
people are Outsourcing their shows for the bottom
line and um it's Max Max it's Max uh I think all
the original series that are uh that got canceled
are gonna get picked up somewhere oh off of Max
hopefully uh fingers crossed but yeah like the
way they use the the artwork is storyboards and
the way they adapt a fair amount of of the Frank
Miller like dialogue style to I mean it's like
especially a parent with characters like uh the
mutants and especially like hi my name is Rob like
like the the little quirks like yeah the t-shirts
and and the way they have their own sort of like
Noir Neo noir-esque parlance that they talk in
with each other and the slang is like obviously
the delightful Frank millerism but even the Batman
speech like the this isn't a mud hole it's uh like
that's all very Frank Miller he's good at those
and I and I do agree the the framing but also the
the poses and iconography like there's certain
images of Frank Miller that sear in your mind
and they would like shape a fight around them
which was really cool and unique totally like
the fight would be made to have that moment and
like pause yeah it was almost like a freeze frame
loved that yeah totally and and two like all the
Talking Heads with all the different news reports
and stuff like that and uh you know just giving
Gotham that extra bit of life around the situation
like that's another thing that I sort of associate
with Frank Miller's style of Storytelling and just
even the Frank Miller Batman stuff that I kind
of remember reading is yeah you have what's the
city chattering about what what is the you know
sort of and I mean people debate Frank Miller's
uh views and subtext and whatever else but I like
that they yeah you utilized that and gave Gotham
and its response to all this its own life I also
love that Frank Miller makes the world feel huge
but also Gotham feel like huge like like you're
saying with the Talking Heads Gotham feels like
a character which is how it should feel like
Gotham is a character and not a lot of creators
do that to the scale and also on top of that this
adaptation allowed that to be like a very integral
part of how they'd tell it yeah yeah absolutely
and and like the way to it uses I do appreciate
like reading some of these iconic like not like
you know uh compendiums and graphic novels and
stuff you know the I think from the outside and
and certainly from like the live-action movie
perspective there's a certain quality where you
expect like okay well there's like a main villain
but I too appreciate where that here you have like
Two-Face and the whole thing with him getting his
reconstructive surgery and what that does to his
mind and then you have the mutants which is like
the main thing but you've also got the looming
threat of the Joker around the corner and you've
got you know somebody like a young person becoming
inspired and stepping into the shoes of Robin and
the fact that it's like a young girl just feels
like kind of a kind of a miller-esque subversion
of of what you'd expect from you know all the
previous Robins prior and because this is a part
one and part two we got to like see her family and
we got to understand her backstory but more than
we might have we got a little bit more Alfred than
we've had in a while we got uh I really liked that
Two-Face was kind of like the opening villain but
also kind of the whole first act like that really
worked well and I haven't read this in in much
longer than I realized because I don't remember
much of it which I'm really enjoying going some
remember the tone I remember the major beats but
a lot of it like I didn't remember if that if
Commissioner Gordon died because Frank Miller
is the kind of guy that would kill him sure so
like yeah I mean like there's a month out from
our tire I mean he's 70 years old that's when
you killed like yeah so I was like there's so
many yeah little suggestions like that too so it's
fun to subvert expectations even within the Miller
idea of things and and I'm really glad I haven't
read it in a while because I I get to be surprised
at the turns it takes yeah this one's great uh
this is probably in the upper third for me this
part one yeah I mean I'm excited to see the second
half and just see how they stick The Landing but I
mean again the amount of like breath that they've
put into this and and just care and atmosphere I
think is really is is really wonderful I don't
know it's very striking and I'd say this is so
like top third for me but it's also I'm gonna
judge them eat separately but this is definitely
gonna go in that like uh when we rank them a lot
I'm sure this is gonna land somewhere near the
top because this is so good yeah absolutely
where's our uh where's our guy yeah what was
a spiky nipple guy's name spiky nip where are you
at what's what's that guy Dark Knight Returns uh
mutants leaders yeah that's what I kept saying oh
he's called me in leader okay is he just called
mutant leader I guess it's very mad maxian
yeah one and two and and that's something I
kind of associate with Yuri's the Son of Batman
oh that makes me so happy oh that's fantastic oh
man have you heard his uh Venom voice uh the
the Symbiote Spider-Man voice the Spider-Man
2 trailer I don't oh no I haven't seen anything
oh it's so cool the Spider-Man 2 trailer he uh
yeah and he does look at this awesome angry Peter
Parker it's so good oh sweet I don't see him yeah
I don't I I unless they named him and I didn't
catch it or something like that I'm not sure I
guess it must be one of these one of these top
names here is he Hernando he's like he's like
mutant leader comma Hernando [Music] um Dark
Knight Returns usually your voice oh no that's
that guy that looks like an exclamation point
uh we had another voice is gonna drive me crazy
Williams there you go oh that's awesome I love
Gary Anthony Williams yeah I was trying to I was
trying to place it because his voice sounded
so familiar too and and it's like you know I
really like the uh yes it is him I thought it was
him okay yeah sure oh he is a delight man he goes
my coffee shop we've become friends and I love
that man very much like he is he is a warm and
welcoming individual and we talk about art all the
time and he is such a nerd like I love this dude
I believe I I kept every time he would speak and
I mean I liked his character voice but I was like
keep I keep thinking about Undercover Brother
I don't know I don't know why I've just got
this feeling that's so cool then yeah like
you know I I do enjoy the voice cast they've
assembled for the dcamu stuff but uh one of
the most fun things about you know going off the
beaten path and jumping out of continuity is you
know instances like these because too like Peter
Weller I think is a terrific uh choice for Batman
yeah and and in a Frank Miller world you know I
feel like I mean you know if it was Kevin Conroy
it would be great sure Jason O'Mara nice to feel
super great from from that to me yeah yeah and I
mean that's part of the fun is like you know
you gotta you gotta temper things you can't
have like a billion trillion Batmans all the time
but you know hearing the different takes is still
part of the fun I've always seen Frank Miller
as not just the future but also kind of an else
world so I think if it was Kevin Conroy I'd be a
little distracted because I'd be thinking of the
Animated Series Batman which I consider a very
specific Batman yeah and I like that the I said
it at the near the top but the Gotham feels
like that art deco animated series mixed with
Frank Miller yeah this is 2012 so this would
have been like decently fresh off the show
um so it's nice to have that world blend so it
feels more approachable and adaptable yeah one
two and two we were in a kind of Miller's Sons by
that time right in terms of like the adaptations
online City would have been recent yeah and
300 would have been around somewhere in here
too mid-2000s so yeah this would have been within
five years five ten years of of the big Sin City
uh 300 era yeah yeah just like all the Striking
shadows and and images yeah it's like I thought
they did a nice job of animating this in a way
where you're like oh definitely inspired by the
Frank Miller work but not like uh obnoxious so
yeah yeah yeah not that I guess it would be but
but yeah I thought they just brought it to Life
In A really lovely kind of way and I love the
tone and the mood and Alfred must be 600 years
old by now it's all good yeah Michael Emerson is
a lot of people's fan casts for the Joker so I'm
really excited to his see his Joker in the next
one sure like to hear that Vibe and like what
that experience that's gonna be great oh yeah
and I love the Slow Burn of like they really only
showed the hymn three times but you're like you
know what's coming like the pacing's great well
yeah and I love that they yeah that they had the
room to play with something like that where yeah
it's like and two it's one of those things where
I think especially this first half you're like
oh yeah he's not even gonna Factor necessarily
but it's just about that Awakening that that
that little uh spark of Life bubbling back up
in the yeah happens in the forward round yeah
darling Oh I love also that like in a theater
I'd probably want these as a full two and a half
hour movie but sure at home I love the hour 15.
because it lets it marinade you get to breathe
in it but also like I'm not at that point of
like okay I've been watching a movie a while like
there are some some I need to be in the theater
for long long long content for whatever reason
just to be fully in it whereas this run time
this pacing everything's perfect yeah because
I was I I glanced at the at the recorder time
a couple of times because I was like oh no is it
gonna end I don't want to end yeah you know and
and I think it's like these movies often fall in
the like hour 15 to hour 25 ish range and uh and
it's always special when you see one where you're
like yeah this felt like an hour and a half hour
and 45 movie but in a good way like it felt longer
than it was in a good way this fully felt like a
feature film like this feels like a complete and I
love that it's half because we got a 3X structure
we got a great Crescendo we got all and it's a
great adaptation of such a beloved book like one
of the more like I don't know if it's gonna make
the top five of all of them but it's one of the
more impressive adaptations of anything I've seen
from comic to any other medium yeah love this and
we got all those comics on the rest all the Alan
Morris I think they're all animal because it was
they look beautiful Vendetta it was Swamp Thing
it was Watchmen Sandman I think it was literally
an Alan morak yeah respect which I was like I
know Frank Miller is written on some of these
characters but those were the ones of Alan Moore
yeah yeah yeah so big fan of the directors are a
huge fan of Alan Moore sure I mean I'm sure
he will never watch this before no but it's
always that's their way to include him yeah like
he won't see this let's just put his covers up
that's the way to get back at him for something
they're like I know what he'll hate he'll hate him
in Canon I like the idea that the the gas station
owner just really loves alibor like he's just
those are for him he did the comics I'm stalking
this is all you get kids learn something yeah
let's get deep and philosophical and there's a
lot of like anti-fascism and stuff in Alan Moore's
work so I love the idea that a fascist Gotham has
like that yeah that's the subversive stuff well
and I mean too uh Frank Miller certainly gets
dogged for his philosophical underpinnings and
uh he's not not a violent man sure and some more
fascist leaning I think in his work and I think
it's interesting bullets you just blow up a lot
of guys yeah which I mean you know is always going
to be I think present in a Batman discussion and
there are times here where he's like ah you know
this guy's Not Gonna Die he'll walk it off or
whatever but yeah I appreciate too it makes me
curious to go back and read the book and see
if these are if those particular because they
do mention like Batman being a fascist fascism
throughout this in little those you know chatter
bits in between and I wonder if that's in the
original text we gotta address the Frank Miller
in the room yeah we gotta I love Frank Miller but
you know it's good uh it's commentary sure sure
yeah yeah it's like I mean Frank Miller writes
some incredibly distinct and engrossing work but
you know it's all part of the process I think the
picking parts of the philosophy Comic-Con the year
uh we were doing comic book shopping second season
other it was like literally right after I got back
from London to Jake Gyllenhaal episode Jake Jalen
episode just aired so like Comic-Con timing was
every Creator being like Oh my God thank you for
getting this like because the word got out about
comics and like we actually caused comic sales and
I remember I uh I was talking to Tom King and I
was so nervous I was more nervous talking to Tom
King Than Jake Gyllenhaal like Tom King is a hero
of mine to a different way and uh Jake's one of my
favorite actors but I talk to more actors for some
reason someone that can create stories I'm always
like it's like people that can make music I'm like
your brain's weird uh I just don't get it like I
don't I don't get how someone hears them and goes
like music anyway I was talking to him and then
he's like oh if you met Frank and he introduced
me to Frank Miller and him and Frank had just
been talking and I was like just let me let's
listen and then Scott Snyder came over and I was
like oh my God and then like Josh Williamson and
it was some of the biggest writers at DC and like
two of my all-time favorite heroes in Tom King and
Frank Miller and I was like got to see them talk
about their Batman like they were literally like
when I came over they were mid Batman conversation
and I didn't see Frank I didn't know like Frank
was there sure and it was just like the most
surreal conversation about what Batman is to
these people sure and I just like didn't want
to speak I was just like let me listen I don't
want to be part of this I said listen it's a
private panel for you it was incredible such an
otter so yeah I got a picture of Tom code Frank
Miller and I was like this is all I wanted uh it
was like 20 minutes I could see her like a lot
and Frank's like 80 something and he still has
so much passion for Batman like to see him like
light up and have a lot to say even though he's
like you know he's older and he looks frail when
he's when he's pontificating it's all power yes
it was really cool what isn't he bad is he got
a new thing out he's doing covers right now but
like this was four years ago and it was it was
like you know he's still very old and frail but
like pontificating you you see a a 50 year old
man instead of 70 or 80 like it was beautiful
that's lovely I'm glad he's out there kicking yeah
I mean I'm so jealous like that sounds yeah like
nerd Valhalla and he was great because he was
like smiling and talking and joyous and as soon
as I asked for a photo he said yes it was really
like happy to do it but he did like yeah he did
like a pose he did like a he did his Rorschach it
was so good so I'm actually like way happier that
I haven't picked with Frank Miller like grimacing
at me and I was like that's all right that's how
I remember him yeah yeah it was It was kind of
got an image tub yeah just like and he did like
a look down and I was like this is so intense
like Frank Miller seems like the kind of guy
who would be a side like like a like a character
only appears once in a Frank Miller graphic novel
to like say something kind of kind of snide
but also like it was not wrong yeah exactly
so yeah the Frank Miller uh Batman is is beloved
to me it's not always how I perceive him but
I love that this returns world so much yeah
absolutely now this is this is Top Notch and
I cannot wait to see the second one yeah love this
uh for me it's like four and a half Stars one of
the higher ones for me it definitely goes in the
top third it's gonna be fun to rank all these if
you want to see us rank them you gotta share
this you gotta leave comment you gotta spread
the words so these videos go everywhere so we
can keep making them uh we were talking right
before I think uh we're gonna do like a separate
one Universe like the DC AMU and then I want to
do all of them and we're there's like 52 so far
by the time we're done there's probably gonna be
like 55. but we want to rank the whole lot so
uh keep sharing these keep loving on them keep
commenting so we can keep doing them we'll be
back very soon for part two uh hopefully within
the week we'll get to part two so keep eyes
peeled hit that notification Bell thank you
all the patrons and uh yeah let's get into the
next one very soon share these love on these
thank you reject Nation you're wonderful we'll see
you very very soon bye go read some comics [Music]